there are two ways to use music as the
foreground itself an object of attention
or as the background that contextualizes
the rest of your world
instrumental music often falls into that
latter category humble and unassuming
most people overlook this kind of music
in favor of music that has a direct
message in fact instrumental music
almost never comes up on the charts in
the same way that songs do it just
doesn't capture people's attention in
the same way and I think that's because
many people misunderstand the role of
instrumental music we often listen to
instrumentals as we would a song and
that's a mistake when we listen to songs
our mind is automatically parsing it for
meaning for understanding of the
songwriters message and if you do that
with an instrumental piece you'll be
sorely disappointed because in an
instrumental meaning and message aren't
explicit that's left up to you and I
want to examine this difference through
the song untitled five by Kendrick Lamar
because there's a significant portion of
the song that isn't instrumental before
Kendrick comes in to rap and this
perfectly illustrates what is gained and
lost when explicit meaning is given in
the beginning of this piece we hear a
jazz sample
[Music]
[Applause]
on its own we may call to mind a friend
a sunny day the smell of espresso a
hipster coffee shop we are free to give
meaning but this vanishes when Kendrick
comes in to rap because he begins to
tell a story I got 100 no my dad wanted
me much mom's name is graphic but my
Bible name is fun so even though we gain
something when Kendrick comes in a
clever story different viewpoints we
also lose something whatever meaning the
song could have held to us after its
intended meaning is explicitly told now
of course there's always room for some
interpretation in song but our
interpretation has been limited you're
no longer in a coffee shop you're in
convicts car it's not a sunny day it's
raining tight on the engine that bad elf
in the rain song and this is how
Kendrick Lamar can help us understand
instrumentals through what we lose when
he starts rapping we lose focus on our
own world which is replaced with his and
there's nothing wrong with that I myself
love getting lost in Kendricks vivid
world but if you understand this
difference between songs and
instrumentals you may find that
instrumentals can fill a gap that songs
camp songs for most people are too
distracting for studying's having a
conversation with someone or reading a
book because they say too much but
instrumentals perfectly lay a move
without computers so assuming you don't
already try turning on an instrumental
for a change and see how it affects you
differently construct your own meaning
and message hey thanks for watching this
video as a help to those of you who are
in big instrumental heads I'm going to
include a bunch of links in the
description that may help you find an
artist you like and those of you who are
ready listening to instrumentals comment
below with your favorite instrumentals
that others might not have heard of
before who are you listening to